odds of panic and he set the tone and  the clipper fans right now mark  couldn't agree more giving a standing  ovation  as jaron lew is emptying his bench  waving the white flag with 2 58  remaining  [Music]  a clipper season is going to come to an  end tonight one that made  franchise and nba history their first  conference final appearance ever  in its 51-year history first team in nba  history to overcome a pair of 02  deficits in the same playoff year  some unforgettable playoff performances  paul george's performance in game five  of the conference final that game six  clincher against utah  when they were down 22 at halftime one  of the great comebacks in playoff  history but it will end tonight  in game six the injuries just too much  to overcome with no kawhi leonard no  sergey baka  zubats didn't play the last couple of  games as chris paul comes up with  another steal  and this is going to be a night of  celebration for the phoenix sun